um the images of the horror and
destruction faced by mario paul have
been on front pages around the world
what is the situation there as you speak
to me now
uh good afternoon the situation is awful
uh russian army continues to do
airstrikes airborne
artillery shelling and
their
troops are behind the city and in some
districts of the city we have
street battles
so as you understand the humanitarian
situation decrease our by our second by
second and ukrainian army tries to
defeat our city at the very moment
um reports no power no water lack of
food
bodies in the streets that can't
be buried and a death toll um official
death toll of 1
300.
how has that changed in the last few
hours
as you understand the situation only
only decreases and becomes worse
so
the numbers that we had official numbers
of dead people
the last information was three days
before
and we had uh 1207
killed people but we should understand
that just
killed people and bodies on this on the
street we cannot uh collect all of them
and
i think i i am scared to tell you the
number of victims we don't know exactly
but we should multiple 10 this number i
i don't know exactly how many
um
mr olav
the humanitarian corridors are not
working uh there's talk of another one
being put in place today for people to
escape
are you optimistic that people can get
out
uh
of course i should stand optimistic and
from our side from uh city council and
from the ukrainian part we do our best
to provide humanitarian corridors so
anyway we are ready to transfer trucks
with humanitarian goods from the parisia
to mariupol but it's the seventh day of
our attempt and
we do not find any solution because
drugs goes
some
some length and they stop over a russian
checkpoint and do not they do not allow
to go
uh to mariupol and as you know we are
the continuous bombing and shelling exa
directly in the city and there is no any
cease fire any ceasefire this night we
had eight
uh cases of air strikes so they are
destroying all the city our by and
killing our civil people
the other thing that made the front
pages of course was the destruction of
your maternity hospital there is is the
search and rescue operation complete
yes we finish rescue operations so
uh we in the center of the city has like
hospital campus there are three billion
there maternity hospital children's
hospital and children's therapy so they
destroy children's uh
hospital and make damages to other
hospitals so we have
uh after this awful bombing and walk
ryan we have
17 victims i mean injured and
affected people it's mostly pregnant
women and
and doctors and three killed
people one of them is a child girl
when you read reports and you hear that
the russian government is saying that
the
the maternity hospital was really a
false flag it was crisis actors
staging it for ukraine
and the children's hospital is fake news
what do you say to that
uh i've read yesterday a good
sentence i want you to know this is the
sentence of ministry of foreign affairs
of latvia he told that you know
we have lie
we have big lie and we have official
information from russia
so it's the very case that he spoke
about so who is uh battalion warriors we
pregnant women or killed child uh we see
a lot of video a lot of photo a lot of
interview from uh
injured people and i
absolutely sure this war crimes will be
punished with the help of the uh with
the help of the court in eu i'm
absolutely sure
and um
reports in the u.s certainly believes
it's um its intelligence believes that
president putin may be about to use
chemical weapons on the people in
ukraine
what are the what are the feelings what
are the fears of people in mario paul
about that you know
without any utility without connection
without everything for eight days they
do not know about this news anything
and you should know that um five to
seven days before uh their best wish
of our people was to
stop somehow the water to stop bombing
to stop shelling
but today and yesterday their best wish
is to find some food and water they even
do not afraid and scared about
continuous bombing and shell and then
just want to find some water and some
food and putting in his army does not
allow to provide any ceasefire and any
humanitarian medical social or any other
help for injured and
suffered people suffering people
and the resistance coming from the
ukrainian army
uh being put up to try to protect what
remains of mario paul
how
how weakened is that and who makes the
decision whether
you fight on to protect your city or
whether you have to surrender who
decides that is that you is it is it
president zielinski
no no we
like city council uh local government
and we
do our best to provide any social
help to
our cities and then to provide all the
utilities so we are on the war and of
course in this
in this situation president is the main
it's his main solution and ukrainian
army it's the responsibility about this
but i want you to know and all the
audience that ukrainian army is very
strong and brave and it can defend
ukraine
uh
and it's i hope it
will do and i'm absolutely sure they do
their best up to the last ballot to
protect mariupol but all should know
that we unfortunately do not have any
weapon to protect our lives
of
um airborne and airstrikes so we told a
lot about it and asked to give us some
weapons to have possibility to protect
our
lives our children our women adults from
this awful airborne
i i want to ask you what while we have
the opportunity to talk to you firstly
have you a message for people who have
relatives who live in mario pole who
haven't been able to get in touch with
them mobile phone networks not working
have you a message for those people who
are desperately worried about their
friends and family
so the situation is that
i should send some message to myself
because i cannot connect with my mother
father and native brother for eight days
i don't know do they alive or not i i
have no message here i'm
i don't know what to send so we will
stay as soon as we can
and you were describing at the start of
this interview the situation that today
still constant frequent bombardments
how often are they coming
during night there was
eight different airplanes that bombed
the city and flattened the city they
absolutely destroyed our biggest steel
plant as of style it does not exist
anymore and they are destroying all the
buildings of the district it's you
should understand it's an unmanaged bomb
with one ton of tritila equivalents so
the diameter of
after this bomb is 30 meter 40 meters so
they're destroying building by building
and reports that some parts of the city
are totally uninhabitable now
it's true
have you a message for
western leaders you have these constant
bombardments they're coming also uh from
the air what is your message to western
leaders
16 days before our country was
free our country was happy and our city
also we are very proud to be
citizens so we do not do not have any
wishes and to attack some other
countries some of the cities so we were
happy to live our peaceful life and to
give as much opportunities to our
citizens
but
we understand that putin and russian
makes an awful
uh awful solution to start war in
mariupol and to provide inside ukraine
as a nation first of all we thought that
their wishes to
win
against ukrainian army but now we
understand that
their wishes ukraine without ukrainians
so they are killing as much citizen as
they can and we ask
uh
we fight here
for being ukrainian we fight here for
be free we fight here to have democratic
government so we fight for all the
uh that the eu has and we
ask for support for further support
we're very thankful for all that was
done about sanction about weapon supply
and we ask more help
and
our best wish to give possibility to
protect our lives against bombing from
the air
and finally mr olof you said that the
soldiers there will fight until the last
bullet how long have you got
i cannot comment i don't know so i
cannot only confirm that up to the last
bullet whether it be days or weekends i
cannot
well we really appreciate you telling us
about the situation there in mario paul
thank you very much indeed for talking
to us and stay safe mr thank you